the british public were ordered to
follow the rules in a deadly pandemic
while the prime minister defied them
they stayed away from the beaches and
the streets only to find that those
setting the rules were breaking them
you must obey the rules
as the country retreated into lockdown
under government orders boris johnson
insisted that no restrictions were
but more and more covered rule breaking
by government officials was leaked and
splashed across the front pages the
public learning of weekly wine evenings
and boozy leaving do's
one bash was on the eve of prince philip
the duke of edinburgh's funeral with a
country in national mourning and queen
elizabeth forced to sit apart from her
family
downing street was forced to issue a
statement of deep regret to buckingham
palace mr speaker i want to apologize
and johnson personally apologized for
attending a drinks party in the downing
street garden
he thought it was a work event he said
and within government rules
is he now going to do the decent thing
and resign the explanation enraged mps
and infuriated the public
career skirting controversy was
floundering
[Applause]
ridiculed by a wine bottle wielding
flash mob outside downing street
we're witnessing every day
the broken spectacle of a prime minister
mired in deceit and deception and unable
to lead
but things were to get even worse for
johnson with claims he had a surprise
birthday bash complete with cake at
number 10 during lockdown
and then a bombshell announcement by
british police they were launching a
criminal investigation into rule
breaking at number 10.
johnson was deemed to have broken the
rules and fined sixty dollars
a month later the report by top civil
servant sue gray made its findings
public
the 48-page report detailed 16 occasions
that breached the law describing a
failure of leadership in downing street
excessive alcohol consumption in the
workplace and gatherings without clear
authorization or oversight
some behavior she said was difficult to
justify against the backdrop of the
pandemic
the question isn't whether boris johnson
was at each and every party during a
time of extraordinary pressure on those
in power
it's about a tone of frivolity that his
leadership set
undermining the most serious office in
the country at a time of national crisis
very good
sony gallego al jazeera london